foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work they love and create actual
amazing relationships
give us a buzz at triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm John deloney
joined here by my good friend Jade
warshaw and we're here to burn this
thing to the ground come on John I hope
you all are doing well triple eight
eight two five five two two five taking
your calls on life money all of it
there's been a lot of Buzz about getting
you you and I on the show together so
I'm excited for it oh yeah I'm excited
for it this is the next decade or so
it's gonna be awesome pure pandemonium
John can't wait let's go to Jennifer in
uh the BCC in British Columbia what's up
Jennifer
hi thank you so much for taking my call
you guys of course thanks for calling
what's up
I'm calling because
um right now I'm just going through a
trying time in my relationship uh my
fiance and I purchased a house last year
um and
I just need his help getting on board
with paying bills
um as well as
just pretty much paying the bells and I
I'm currently on maternity leave and I
was wondering if I should come off of
maternity leave
um to double our income so that we're
able to pay off our bills faster what's
beneath money's a part of this there's
what else is happening
to us so I think what happens is along
with the bill
um that they kind of rely on me so if
everything is not paid my parents will
pay for it and I'm just in a stage of my
life where I kind of want to stand on my
own and not really have so much help
from my parents and I'm just trying to
get my partner on board with my fiance
on board so that we could crush our like
Financial debts together so he's resting
on The Laurels of your parents being the
safety net am I am I Gathering that
correctly
pretty much I have a big problem with
this the whole thing sounds like a mess
I have I have a big problem you're
you're pregnant how far along are you
no I'm on the train oh you're on leave
okay yeah she's currently five months
right now
um so here in Canada we get like a year
um so right now I'm just making 80 of my
income from my job but if I go back to
taking contracts and coming off of
maternity leave I could make 100 or Plus
what's he making
um a month
appear like if you're at 80 of your
income is he at 100 of his and what does
that mean she is I 100 of his
and how much is that
um a month keeping this home after taxes
uh roughly four thousand dollars
what problem are you trying to solve
Jennifer
I can't tell if you remember if I mean
you're not married but I can't tell if
your relationship is falling apart if
y'all are in the hole financially what's
what's happening
it's both
because I'm one I don't know another 20
is going to change your life much
[Music]
I agree but
it's just a miscommunication between us
and I think because I'm totally Dave
Ramsey and he's not it makes things a
lot harder if I say let's create a
budget let's do this together he's just
like well it's okay we'll work things
out so that's a foundational thing you
know
um you've got to be able to work
together and this is a really strong
indicator
that this is not going to just come up
in finances this is going to come up in
so many other areas of your life
and you got to be able to work together
why is he so dismissive of your needs
I think because he knows that like we
have a safety net I think no no no no
that's different than that's that's
Financial right that's that's Financial
when you say I want this or I need this
and he's like I don't care
why is he so dismissive
I'm not sure to be honest
hmm I think you guys have got some some
real work to do some real digging to do
I hey can I just be honest with you
if it were me this would be a major
major red flag and I know you've got a
kid with this dude now but this is this
is a problem and what John is getting at
is that it's far deeper than money and I
agree with him wholeheartedly now on the
phone today I I'm happy to help you with
with the money stuff but please please
don't let that make you feel like it's
solved okay
do we agree if I help you with the money
if I help you with the money stuff we
know the relationship stuff is not
solved okay
yeah so give me give me a couple of
numbers so I can give you give you a
jump off point here
okay
so what kind of debt do you guys have
um we have like office of our mortgage
and then we owe about forty thousand
dollars to our line of credit okay is
that
credit cards or it's a it's a HELOC what
kind of line of credit
um it's just um a credit card okay
anything else
no that's it no cars no student loans no
no but okay definitely those kind of
aspects and so you said you're at 80 of
your income how much is that a month
um right now I bring in about 45
so you guys are about 80 8 500 a month
yes okay here's the thing you do need to
get on a budget you know that so let's
start budgeting because here's how
here's the thing you're not married so
you're well within your means to do your
finances on your own he's just your
fiance at this point uh whether you go
forward onto marriage is one thing but
right now you Jennifer need to get on a
budget with your forty five hundred
dollars a month and if I'm you I'm not
going to depend on his money like that
if he wants to put money towards paying
for the kid that's fine but pay off your
debt don't pay off his debt so how much
of that 40K is yours and how much of it
is his
um as both of ours it's joined
no it's not
oh it's it is it's a joint like credit
card that we have to make purchases for
a house
okay so right from this day forward keep
those finances separate okay because I
don't like how this looks going forward
for you and I don't want you to continue
to get deeper and deeper in shared
finances with someone who that you're
not married to because this could get
real messy real fast am I right John it
already is I want remember this line
Jennifer behavior is a language
and without using words your husband is
telling you he has no I mean your fiance
is telling you I've got no interest in
partnering with you on this deal I have
no interest in creating a life together
with you
we do have a kid congratulations to us
but I've got no interest in anything
other than what I'm interested in
and if you're my sister if you're my
daughter I'm telling you to get away
from that guy
and
um I'm telling you as your friend be as
open and honest about what you need and
so instead of sitting down and saying
hey I wanted we need to do the Dave
Ramsey plan
say fiance I'm scared to death and I
can't breathe we have a new baby I'm
scared to death owing forty thousand
dollars I'm sick and tired of calling my
mommy and my daddy to come bail us out
it's time for me to be an adult and I
want to invite you to be an adult with
me
and maybe for the first time he'll hear
it because you're going to be honest and
open for the first time too this is not
a money issue this is a relationship
issue let's start there we'll be right
back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
cschm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined with my good friend Jade warshaw
and we are taking your calls on money
and live triple eight eight two five
five two two five we're talking money
talking your marriage your relationships
your mental health your work whatever's
going on holler at us triple eight eight
two five five two two five and before we
get to this video here
don't forget
um it costs literally nothing I know
times are hard times everybody's
strapped
um that includes me and Jade where
everybody's dealing with this stuff man
um
a great way you can support this show
and more importantly than supporting the
show um we're fine we've had each other
on the back a lot really it's a gift to
that single mom with two kids who sit at
home who's stuck and doesn't know what
she's doing and she's just scrolling
YouTube because she's finally got a
moment of Peace after her kids are in
bed or that Over The Road Trucker who's
just pulled into another rest stop and
he's just scrolling through YouTube or
listening to podcasts
your likes your when you hit the
Subscribe button your five star reviews
it helps kick the show up into the
algorithm and makes it available to more
people so that they can get the help
that they need and if you've been a
beneficiary of that not asking for your
money I'm asking you just to hit
subscribe just hit uh just leave a five
star review and just said help change my
life and that will get that information
in front of more people it's a great way
to support us and more importantly to
support your neighbors
um and it didn't cost you anything all
right so Jade what's up
um
James producer James sent us a video yes
he did Chad Ocho Cinco Johnson yeah uh
former NFL
um wide receiver did an interview with
Shannon sharp on his Club shayshay
podcast
um James is a huge Club podcast fan
that guy talks about that all the time
um but we got a couple of videos here
um he was speaking some stuff that might
sound a little bit wild he I I you know
he was talking about money and what he
does with his money and let's let's let
the people let's let's let the people
hear it all right so here is the part
one of the video don't try to live a
lifestyle you can't afford
when people they think the Cure and the
problem the fix for the problem is will
give me more money I'm gonna be all
right but the more you make the more you
spend right if you have no discipline
and no structure yes absolutely every
time yes every time well just give me
more and more no the more you get the
more you're gonna spend and people ain't
gonna listen because we are caught up in
looking a certain way living a certain
way trying to appease others who don't
really care nothing about you yeah he
has to say oh I got it wow
I got a two and a half for almost 30
years I didn't save what 80 83 of my
salary I don't need validation from
nobody on the outside that's another
downfall in society we always need
validation exceptions from others so
try to live a lifestyle that you know
you can't afford right you can't you
can't you can't do that
all right so you gotta you got a pro
football player it said in the in the in
the copy there he flew Spirit Airlines
instead of chartering a jet this guy
made millions and millions and millions
yeah right
um instead of flying Southwest I'm
flying Spirit right I mean fake jewelry
the whole thing
because he's like man I I don't have to
prove myself to everybody I love it I
love it I've been guilty of that I've
been guilty of being in situations where
I feel like I have to prove like I
belong here and the way to prove I
belong is by you know having the same
the same bag she has having the same
shoes they have and if you do that it's
like a status thing but it's so deeply
rooted in insecurity it really is like
that's not and I heard him say on
another part of the interview too like
that's not what gives you your worth
like what you can buy are you kidding me
yeah so I really I mean I love that it
makes me think of that scripture one
person pretends to be rich yet has
nothing
and another pretends to be poor but has
great wealth
I mean what do you want to do you want
to you want to be fake rich or real Rich
you know what I'm saying and I just I I
like what he said this show is a lot
about
um like exact ratios and what's the
exact percentage before I do this and
the ratio before I do this and this yeah
and so I don't want to get caught up in
the in the numbers here but saving 80 of
his income yes he's extreme well but
he's also making millions and millions
yeah and I I have been guilty of the he
was exactly right yeah I've spent my
entire career my thinking well if I just
made some more money then fill in the
blank and what ends up happening is my
house is gotten a little bit bigger my
car's got a little bit nicer and I and I
realized a few a few jobs ago this just
never stops until I stop it the goal
post keeps moving every single time see
what I did there yes I see what you did
there okay well played don't try to live
a lifestyle you can afford yeah
here's the hard truth of this it's easy
to look at at Ocho single and say okay
he's worth millions and millions
so what we are saying and I'll say you
can join me or not
if you make sixty five thousand dollars
as a teacher
you've chosen a Corolla life and that is
okay you've chosen a Camry life until
yeah you can like was it the third the
third job that's that's a Millionaire
right there's engineers and something
else in teachers yep that's right um on
the list so you can get there absolutely
but you don't get to decide well I I
want to have an 80 000 Suburban which is
used by the way right when yours take
home salary 65 000 like we have to live
relative to the job we make instead of
trying to live a lifestyle that we can't
afford I mean I definitely think yeah
for him saving 83 of his income looks
totally different than like you said a
teacher somebody who's making an average
salary it's not the same I mean I I
don't save 83 of my income are you
kidding me like you I'd be wearing a
cardboard box right now so well and I
know there's teachers across the country
that just rolled their eyes when I said
65 000 like I don't know what teachers
make not that yeah but it's it's when
you
let me just say it this way
stop trying to pretend to live somebody
else's life if you've made the choice to
have job X or job y or it's the only job
you get that's fantastic and be so proud
of yourself be grateful of the
contribution you're making
and live that lifestyle absolutely yeah
you've gotta it's it points to
contentment and again I feel like we do
have to highlight the ratios because
it's a lot easier for him to quote it's
easy to say oh it's easy for him to live
on 20 he's got millions but to his point
the the like we said the goal post is
always moving and it's interesting
because you're always comparing yourself
to what's around you like I was watching
something I think it was Kevin Hart and
he was talking about you know if you're
on a a basketball team or a football
team you're hanging out with those guys
they're not all making the same money
that's right what is the difference
between if you're like first string and
if you're like I don't know like the
Sixth Man or like over on the on the
sidelines and we're talking hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars
difference right in Pay right so it's
like hey after the game we're all going
out yeah really like you're not doing
what the quarterback's doing and it's
the same thing in our our own life if I
go out with a bunch of folks it's easy
to think hey we're all here we can all
afford the same things and you can't
that's right I mean how many times you
go to dinner with people and it's like
hmm well they ordered the steak I guess
well maybe I'll order it too like and
you start changing your your behavior
based on who you're around you go to
work you start looking at the cars in
the parking lot oh well there well maybe
I need that too and you start comparing
yourself but you don't know you don't
know their life you only know your life
and you're the one that's got to sleep
at night that's exactly right and we
often don't understand that somebody's
mom passed away and left them a bunch of
money okay or somebody's Granddad passed
away and left them a house or somebody
else is struggling and that's why they
drive that car because they don't care
about this dumb depreciating asset on
Wheels they're more interested in saving
your college funds we just make all
sorts of stories up about or people in
the parking lot next to us yeah stop
yeah I just live your life um all right
let's go to the second one um he has a
part two to this um roll it James
but everybody's caught up an image and
looking a certain way and being rich
it's me
it's pointless you know how hard it is
to live like that all the time
consistently and be fly every day
jewelry and listen
Heirs of rappers think about the era
before before us right everybody was
flashy stunned and stunned and after 10
years what happens
oh you can't it's impossible to sustain
right it's impossible
oh I love that he's talking about
athletic culture hip-hop culture because
78 of athletes are losing their wealth
within three years and it's because of
the culture more bags Gucci belts you
know bottle service you know Maseratis
like Bentley's like this is the culture
I'm so glad that somebody's talking
about that telling us that it's not
necessary this is not what's giving us
our wealth rappers are not the people
who tell us how we have to dress John
Jay-Z don't tell you what car you have
to drive okay John he does he texted me
the other day until May actually get
some new clothes and so I am going Sean
look if Jay-Z if Queen B calls me I'm
coming but I am not taking out a 401k to
loan to do it all right we'll be right
back on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined by Jade warshaw
we're taking your calls on money and
life let's go to Tony in Savannah what's
up T-money how we doing
hey how are you sir thank you for taking
my call you got it my brother what's up
hey we have a military retirement and a
VA retirement and my wife and I were
wondering we have no debt other than the
health
and we're wondering if the VA and the
military retirement can be used towards
the three to six months of emergency
fund and we can take the rest of the
funds the stocks the gold the silver
that stuff and put it towards our house
to pay it off what do you think
that's an interesting question I'm gonna
dig a little bit further so how much are
you getting from the VA
I get
18 17 1600 right now okay and the other
military one
is I get
I think total between both of them is 60
850 bucks that's the total between all
of it 68.50 yeah okay and is there any
other income coming in
oh yeah my wife work I work
um
this is probably total including that is
probably about 150 000 a year okay so I
would just honestly I would treat this
just as part of your normal income
and walk through the baby steps as
though it's part of your normal income
so it sounds like you said you have no
other debt you're working on the three
to six months of savings is that correct
well we have that
um the three the three months of savings
would be about 24 000. okay and we have
that and you have that okay
and then we're thinking about
can I stop there use this money to just
go right into the house debt and get it
and get rid of it
well with the rest of the money well I
kind of continue to walk up so this
payout this 68.50 that's forever correct
correct and do you have any other
retirement savings besides that
um oh life has a 401k we have about a
hundred thousand dollars in in gold and
other things okay yeah so let's continue
to walk up the baby steps again treating
all of this as though it's income like
regular income putting 50 15 of your
household
income including this money into your
401ks Roth IRAs and maxing those out and
then just walking up the baby steps um
no kids college to save for
none okay then now we're going to the
house so once you're at 15 of that
retirement contribution then I would
start you know doing extra towards the
house does that make sense
sure and understanding that I just want
to make sure I'm clear understanding
that the 15 is on top of what I already
make the 6800 because we're counting
that as just income towards our living I
would how big are those nest eggs
I'd like to say we've got about a
hundred thousand sitting there 100 000 I
mean yeah that's not gonna I mean it's
great that you have it if you if you
wanted to keep that separate and just
take your normal income and invest that
at the 15 I think that's fine it's it
doesn't make sense to take it out of an
investment and reinvest it you know what
I'm saying so I would take your normal
income and do it like that
I would also sell all their single
stocks all your gold and silver get rid
of that crab yeah you don't need that
and put that cash towards your house I
wouldn't have a problem with that that's
great John
perfect how much you have in all that
nonsense
um probably about 70 000. oh yeah what
are you Tony what are you doing what are
you on the house
um 230 000. oh yeah I like John's idea
let's let's get 70k liquid as soon as
possible throw that at the house and uh
bump up your retirement to 15 out of
your take-home pay man you're going to
be home free in a minute with this house
that's exciting right okay can I ask you
a personal question but I'm not putting
you on blast on the radio I just really
want to know
um why why gold and silver like what is
that so you're in the military like you
have either seen it with your own eyes
or worked with people who have seen it
like what happens when it goes down
what about worried about the gold and
silver makes you feel warm inside
it wasn't warm inside it was more of a
safety valve we were a little bit
worried
about
um the stocks dropping so far that we
just rolled it
just so that you had something other
than 401ks so you're saying if there was
a major stock market drop you just liked
knowing that you had something else
there yeah I mean that sounds correct
there's a lot of people that feel that
way I get the sentiment I just my
promise to you is it won't save you if
that actually happens
I had a buddy of mine
um he's a he's a banking Guru and I've
told the story a few times but we were I
I was dude I was hammering him I had a
whole list of things like what happens
when the market does this and the US
dollar is going to collapse I was going
after him I was like this and then this
and then this and he said something that
I'll remember for the rest of my life he
said
he realized what I was asking and what I
was asking was make me feel not anxious
not answer all my math problems and he
finally said hey dude I don't have a
meteorite plan and I said what do you
mean and he said dude I'm putting money
in retirement I paid my house off and
this is a banker nothing to do with Dave
Ramsey
um he's like I'm paying I'm I'm taking
all of the variables off the table that
I can take off which is I don't owe
anybody anything
um I've got retirement
and if the entire wall street collapses
and here's here's this quote your
neighbor's gonna try to shoot you for
your water and your gold and silver
won't save you and the way he described
I was like oh yeah I'm planning for an
imaginary apocalypse and so it was this
it was I was I was in a weird way I was
free after that
um I I I get the I want to have an exit
strategy I want to do these things what
happens is people tie up seventy
thousand dollars while every month
you're making a payment to make a
mortgage company rich and I'd rather you
take care of those variables and take
them off the table so that if something
collapses and no one can come take your
house from you no one can come take you
or fill in the blank your cars from you
because you don't owe anybody anything
on them which is a different proposition
then hey guys I got silver bars you want
to trade like man that's that's not
gonna get you very far when somebody
wants your water right
um but thank you so much for the call
Tony
um by the end of today what you're gonna
be
160 000 on that mortgage that'd be
awesome yeah no like 130 he's going to
be closer than that didn't he say it was
200 that's just 250 but okay either way
he's making his move man yeah my guy's
about to be
debt free home included all right let's
go uh to William in Chicago what's up
William
hey Don thanks for taking my call can
you hear me well absolutely my brother
what's up
hey man uh super excited uh again thank
you
um really um so I've purchased the car
last year and just um I love the car I
want to keep it but uh
um this was before me reading Rachel's
book and and getting into Dave
um so now I'm kind of wondering uh at
one point is it worth to keep it
um you know I I think I can
I think if things go well just like you
did last year I think I can get it paid
off within 12 months but it is really a
toy car
how much is it worth yeah
um so it's worth about 80. I dropped
about uh 40 for a down payment
so what's the monthly payment on it
um it's seven
um 700 but uh I'm up right now I'm
paying a thousand a month and then
um I I mean I have the money I have
I have money and and savings that I can
pay it off completely but that would
kind of leave me with just a little bit
of um how much you make how's your
salary
um so what we do sales right so I mean
I've averaged over a hundred uh Last
year me and the wife brought in uh I'd
say about 250. how many cars do you have
uh I got the wife has your own car I got
my car
um the bullets about
fairly new I would say so between the
three cars what are they all worth
combined
um all combined probably there was about
a hundred okay
so the way we teach is we wouldn't want
you to have
more than half of your annual income
tied up in in cars my thing is if you've
got the money to pay this off if this is
your only debt you've got the money to
pay it off why not just pay it off and
be free of it if you're going to pay it
off in 12 months I'm fine with that it
sounds like it's not killing you you're
just like should I should I not if you
can pay it off paid off if you know baby
step to it if you don't want to do that
pay it off in a year get rid of it and
just remember that rule of thumb no more
than 50 of things going down in value
should be more the 50 of your take-home
pay annually this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
eight eight two five five two two five
listen this is a super exciting day I
get to announce something I'm jazzed
about our money and marriage event is
back but it's gonna be wilder than ever
before today I get to announce the money
in marriage getaway join Rachel Cruz and
me and several others right here in
Nashville for a weekend long getaway in
October that will have you and your
spouse feeling more aligned and
connected than ever before the money
marriage getaway is designed for you and
your spouse to disconnect from everyday
life and the anxiety and the stress and
the worry and all that Mayhem
focus on your marriage I'm hearing all
over the country marriages are hanging
on by thread
this is for you listen it's Valentine's
and right now you're overflowing with
love for your spouse ah gross and
thinking about the romantic night that
you two have planned
or some of you are like oh crap it's
Valentine's Day that kind of connection
with your spouse shouldn't happen just
once or twice a year for some
manufactured holiday as part of the
getaway you're gonna get a fun date
night experience time set aside to
reflect and grow together and plenty of
encouragement and ideas from me and
Rachel Cruz that will help the two of
you stay on the same page about your
money
your marriage sex and intimacy all of it
we're going there and it's going to be
fantastic plus we're super excited to
meet you in Nashville in person here's
the thing it's expensive it's an
intimate three-day event the ticket
prices start at 6.99 699 bucks that's
good I know I was gonna say it's
expensive but it's actually not right
there three nights yeah come on John so
if you're in baby step two this event
isn't for you this year head to
ramseysolutions.com events to get more
info and save your spot it's gonna sell
out it's gonna sell out quick Nashville
is a fun place to be and we're gonna
have all kinds of fun things planned for
you over the course of a weekend and we
are really looking forward to it go to
ramsesolutions.com
events to get more info and save your
spot some of you are gonna stop by you
know the grocery store on the way home
to pick up some flowers don't
buy your wife a weekend getaway marriage
retreat in Nashville okay phew I was
like what do you say that's a good move
so last night lately last night I'm
walking into my house
and I was sitting in the car uh I got
home and I was putting my stuff away and
I was scrolling one last time I was
gonna check my email check my Instagram
before I went in one last girl my wife
had I know the things one last girl but
my wife had sent me a DM as a poem from
Mary Oliver and it was it was a long
poem but it just started with I don't
want your flowers and it was like I want
this I want this one I don't want your
flowers and I walked in the front door
and I'm reading this thing carrying a
bouquet of flowers and I just handed to
my wife and I was like sorry I just got
your message and she started laughing it
was fun that is funny I like flowers my
husband gets me flop look I came home
there was flowers
see and and I said to Sam I was like
I've never gotten a box of chocolates
for Valentine's Day I always saw it on
TV I I always got like I don't know
teddy bears or a nice dinner I just
wanted a box I wanted like the just like
the sappy just this is what Valentine's
Day I was like I want roses and I want a
box of chocolates and he got you that's
what I got he got them all the way from
Oregon box of chocolates that guy knows
what's up delicious to go man
um I'm getting my wife
a uh a one-person ticket to the money
marriage of it she can just sit in the
audience and listen to her husband
lecture other people on how they should
be married she'll love that oh gosh all
right let's go to Jennifer in Los
Angeles what is up Jennifer
hi
hi thanks for calling calling what's
happening
uh so I always have a question uh my
husband and I always wonder how much
should we be budgeting for fun money
every month is there like a ratio or
percentage did my wife tell you to call
no it sounds like we should connect
problem no you should I should keep
y'all two apart Jay what's what's the
rule of thumb here well let me guess
Jennifer you're the spender in the
relationship
we are both really Frugal actually
that's why okay this question is coming
from you know I I don't really play this
by ratio per se or like percentage I
kind of take it a case-by-case basis and
look at what's going on are you guys in
debt like tell me a little bit more
about your financials if you will
uh so we our only debt is our mortgage
we own about 500 000 on our health okay
um it's worth about 1.2 1.3
um and uh no we both work I am an
assistant to a financial advisor and my
husband is a pharmacist we have a
one-year-old daughter good deal
um so when you're doing your budget and
you've got margin left over right now
what are you doing with that money
you're putting some in savings you're
investing like are you on baby step four
at this point investing the 15 percent
uh
wait and 15 into retirement
uh yeah so we each have 50 15 going to
our 401K Suite
um and after that we have a few thousand
dollars every month but we don't really
pay off the house with it we kind of
just put it into a joint account and I
invested every once in a while so here's
the thing when it comes to the first
couple baby steps those are all about
being super intense right it's like
we're not going to restaurants we're not
going out to eat we're not going on
trips it's like that but once you get to
the final baby steps four five and six
it's more about being intentional I do
think that you should be putting money
towards paying off your house but I also
think you all need to have fun you guys
have worked hard everything's going well
you do need to budget for fun I'm not
going to tell you and that must be 300
I'm not gonna make that choice for you
but I do think that it's important that
you have a little bit of money
um that you do things with and that your
husband has a little bit of money that
he does things with and that you both
have things that you do together
um and you can call it fun money you can
call it you know Jennifer's money what's
your husband's name
uh John John can have his line item
John's hundred dollars Jennifer's
hundred dollars and you know I think
that if you plan for it you will feel
better about spending it I have found
that with frugal people it's like uh I'm
just like can I honestly go to Target
and spend like I don't know 200 if it's
on the budget and you're following the
plan you're handling business yes the
answer is yes you can there's three
things you can do with money you can
give it you can save it and you can
spend it and a lot of times when we're
very frugal we come on John talk about
spending because I know that you got the
type the type of strings I spit I spin
too much actually here's what's helped
us in our house Jennifer is instead of
having a fun money line
um
I will say I would like to buy another
guitar like it's an actual purchase that
we head towards my wife will actually
actually ask me
um I'm assuming you're gonna go hang out
with some friends this month because
you're you need to stop being so lonely
you need to go out and have some friends
how many times are you going to go out
um and how much how much do you want me
to put in that line so sometimes fund
money for planners is to amorphous but
put it towards a thing when y'all sit
down and do your budget every month and
you look at your calendar and match
schedules hey you're going to go out
with some of the people from the
pharmacy once a week how much you want
me to put in that line and that's
different than fun money because fun
money at the end of the month is easy to
if you're super Frugal it's easy just to
put into a a retirement account and
you're going to wake up and be 65 and
realize you haven't lived your life yet
and so plan for some of these things I'm
gonna buy a book once a month I'm going
to go have lunch with my girlfriends
once a month like whatever the thing is
make it about specific items instead of
just this slush fund
um and for uh
for me I like having a slush fund it
makes me feel happy inside I do too I
like that on the budget it says Jades
and it does say fun money it says Jade's
fun money and I could take that money
out in cash I don't have to answer
nobody's questions about it John I I
come back with things and Sam is like
hey what's that I'm like it's my fun
money it's okay it's my fun money John
what's the next guitar on your list to
buy my dude I'm struggling man I really
want a flying v-bad but I also I want
another one I want another one Ben don't
judge and I also really really want a uh
Gibson Firebird
and one of uh Sam's paulry Smith I just
love that Sam is out there like shaking
his head at the Flying B and shaking his
head yes at the pra
there's only a few people who can hang
with the flying V's man one day one day
James hey that's uh first hour in
here on the Ramsey Show take care of one
another take care of your money and
we'll see you soon next hour
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsey Way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
actual amazing relationships I'm John
deloney joined here by my good friend
Jade warshaw and we are taking your
calls on money life your marriage what's
going on in your workplace whatever you
got going on your life we got you triple
eight eight two five five two two five
it's triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go out to Eric in
Philadelphia where he was born and
raised in the playgrounds where he spent
most of his days what's uh let's see
here what's up Eric how we doing
hi there David how are you I'm I'm John
I'm I'm sitting in for Dave today but
I'm doing great okay how are you
um good to hear John um I want to let
you know I'm a big fan of your show I
like your show and I've been following
your advice
um long story short I don't want to get
in the way the full scenario if we need
to do that and I'll need to sit with an
advisor but I'm low income and I filed
for bankruptcy about three years ago
which I know you're against that but it
was the best thing that could happen to
me because I learned the financial
lesson I um as a result of being low
income do not want to own a car I do not
want to lease the car and that is
completely off the table and I received
professional advice against doing that
and I'm fully agreeing with that I also
agree with Dave's advice about not
bothering with credit cards because
that's off the table what I was advised
to do was to rent a car from Enterprise
when you need it because my insure and
my other advisors told me you want to be
the type of person that you want to use
the car or when the car is done you hand
it over and say it's your problem now
you want to take the damage waiver out
and everything I normally advise against
that but in your case I'm for it however
as you know for those car rental places
it contradicts Dave's advice and you
need a credit card to rent from them and
I don't want a credit card is there any
tactic or way of advisement get around
it because I'm bankrupt and it would
cost me more for a credit card obviously
to get the bank card that I don't want
to begin with then it would be worth but
it's more feasible to rent the car what
do I do because it contradicts sure sure
let me tell you this first
um
you've been through hell and back
haven't you
yes
to work
so what I want to tell you is just
guide a guy friend a friend now
I'm glad you're back and you've been
through it
and you've got more
advice and people jawn at you and people
coming after you it's been a rough
season and I want you to know I'm
grateful for your call and I'm grateful
for these boundaries you're putting in
place in your life
um there's gonna come I'm grateful that
you've been able to take my call because
I haven't been able to get through to
the show and today I just decide
randomly I'll try it luckily I got
through I'm more grateful that you took
the call well that's that's awesome
um
so there's there's long story short I
travel all over the country I'm I'm gone
probably a week and a half sometimes two
weeks a month
I rent cars all over the nation and I
don't have a credit card
I use my debit card
can you okay I do have
um on on the on the debit card that I
travel with I do have space and so I am
fortunate that if they put a 300 hold or
whatever that's okay I'm okay with that
I know not everybody's in that situation
okay
um I want to go back before and I by the
way and I've also run into trouble I've
I've just I I was just telling Jade off
air we were talking about this and I
said I one time was sitting at a at a
the car rental counter in Dallas Texas
and I looked at the person working and I
said can you please figure out a way
that I can give you my money I'm trying
to pay you and she would it was just it
was such a mess I ended up having to
leave and I had to go to another counter
they took my money right away and had me
in a car within two minutes and then
we're out the door
that said I really want to challenge the
wisdom and again you've got people
working with you and you you and I have
known each other for 90 seconds now
right I want to challenge the wisdom
that you are taking a very expensive way
to get yourself around
and when I want to go expensive I like
to go luxury because it's only
occasional Eric are you still walking
through the bankruptcy or is it complete
like was it chapter seven it's finalized
to chapter seven it's finalized good die
it's gone and I'm proud of it I wouldn't
want to do it any other way okay
basically and I'm attached only and so
where are you at now with your income
I'm just low income I'm in housing type
situation okay how much or if you know
if you don't feel comfortable saying it
that's fine but I'd like to be able to
help you as accurately as possible
how much um what do you need to know I
wanted to know what you're earning a
month because I want to find out your
debt is gone you know everything's been
liquidated I want to know what you're
left with and kind of what your plan
going forward is because I agree with
John renting cars is not sustainable
you're going to spend more on the long
haul you can get a cash car at some
point not today but we want to get you
on a plan that's going to be sustainable
and you keep referring to yourself as
low income as though it's an identity I
want to disagree with that's not who you
are brother that's where you find
yourself right now that's not who you
are yeah okay yeah um basically I get
800 a month and my portion of rent is
300 and then housing's portion
um and basically the rest of the money
is goes on whatever else necessary Foods
groceries Tran like Transit card things
like that it's basically gone by the
time it makes there after the bills are
you on disability are you unable to work
um it's a long story but yes I don't
want to get into that situation on the
air if you want to speak with me about
it on a more or connect me with an
advisor I can get into that portion but
yes we definitely want to do that we
definitely want to get you connected
with somebody that you can help you
financially and I'm going to have Austin
pick up afterwards because there's a lot
more to this and um and I agree but I
just you know it's time constraining for
the show right to the point with that
going on
I mean then that's this is the fact what
what John said you're going to run into
an issue with that because when you do
use a debit card they're saying hey yeah
we'll do this but your liability to us
so they're going to charge a lot more on
your card they're going to put those
holds on there
um if you're going from place to place
sometimes they'll even say like you've
got to show us your ticket if you're
flying somewhere your ticket here and
your ticket returning like they they do
put they make it hard for people who
honestly just want to pay cash for
things they do and so in your situation
where your income is so limited I don't
believe that this is the best possible
thing for you long term but in the short
term do know that you are going to run
into those problems and I know you
mentioned you do like to do Luxury when
you do do it it it's not a season for
luxury right now
um I totally get that sentiment and that
feeling that's just not the season
you're in right now and here's the thing
Jay this is the choice I made kind of
like what if I've got a diet restriction
I'm always doing these weird diets and I
go to your you and Sam's house for
dinner I'm not gonna impose that on you
guys I get to make choices about what I
mean because it's that's on me yeah so
when I go to a rental car counter I'm
not mad at them they're making my life
hard but I chose this this no credit
life that's right and so be it man I'm
not going to lose sleep because y'all
don't want my business right I know
that's right good point all right this
is the Ramsey Show we'll be right back
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 45 off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
hey what's up America if you're a new
listener and you want to dive deeper
into the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button everyone's always calling
asking us where are we how do I know
what step I'm in we got you we got you
we'll help you figure out the best next
step for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on get
started all right we got question of the
day today's question comes from Rachel
in Utah cool my question is how can I
combine finances as a newly married
couple it's his second marriage when
your spouse has no budgeting discipline
and has no limits to giving his children
money frivolously I have good credit and
we discuss these things before marriage
I feel trapped
John I feel like there's some stuff
beneath the surface here say it like
this is a question you should not a
question you all discussed these things
before marriage
my guy flipped the script you never made
any decisions before marriage and y'all
didn't come up with any plans before
marriage and you didn't have any ideas
you probably had a conversation over
lunch like hey budgeting's a big deal
and yeah sure that's cool and y'all
never made one y'all never sat down and
said hey what do we want our marriage to
look like in 10 years and what do we
start after do what do we have to start
doing right now so we can be there in 10
years yeah well there's also this side
to it where he's giving his children
money frivolously
and I want to know more about that
because that's from his previous
marriage maybe there's something there
where he's like this is all I can do to
like and maybe maybe this is somebody
that's never had kids and this money
isn't frivolous at all this is what it
costs raise kids so who knows Rachel
these are all questions you should have
asked before you got married and you
should have been super clear
and here's the deal you have married
somebody with kids great that's awesome
that means you have made a choice you
chose to be in some sort of relationship
with his ex-wife forever forever you
have chosen to participate in the
raising of two kids that are not
biologically yours forever those are
just choices you made and so don't go to
war with those you also chose to marry
somebody who's super immature with money
you knew this before you said I do you
did
um and so what you can do moving forward
is one of two things
I would start with number one which is
to sit down and say we are a few months
in we're a year into this new marriage
and I'm scared to death and I can't
breathe
I can't breathe because I don't know how
much money we have I don't know where
it's going I want to own a home someday
with you I want to build a life I want
to be able to share in this adventure
that we both signed up for
and the way money is leaking out our
back door it scares me to death and I
can't move can you help me please I
don't feel safe that's number one that
by the way that's a that's making the
entire issue not his fault not he's got
no discipline and he's just that's about
you and what you're feeling and what
your body is trying to get your
attention for right that's number one
number two
if he looks at you and says listen honey
I'm never going to not give my kids
money ever ever ever I'm not budgeting
budgeting is stupid
then I classify that I I think we often
when it comes to
um marital Fidelity we often are get
laser focused in on sex and I think
Fidelity is a much bigger picture about
how you treat the person you're married
to and so
um this is somebody who is choosing to
not be in relationship with you and at
some point you become unsafe and you're
gonna have to either create an account
that is yours that you can begin to plan
a budget for you take yourself to
counseling or you're going to start
deciding is this marriage safe overall
because usually Jade in situations like
this there's something else going on it
sounds like there is I it honestly when
I look at it my you know I try to see
the the best in things John I always go
to the darkness you went to the dark
side quick but I I I'll pull it back for
us who were kind of like maybe it's not
that bad I kind of feel like there might
have just been a difference in
vocabulary like the pictures yeah like
what words mean what does frivolous mean
what does budgeting mean you know what I
mean and I think that sometimes you have
those conversations early on and you
kind of just don't know what you don't
know it's like oh yeah budgeting I grew
up with that yeah yeah I budget and then
it's like but like Dave Ramsey budgeting
is different from you know what I mean
the budgeting some of us grew up with so
I think there could be just the lines
are crossed
um only she knows really what's going on
but I think when you have those
conversations and you approach it from
instead of approaching it from I'm mad
at you I'm angry with you but kind of
from like I'm scared yeah I think that
if you're a good guy and your woman is
telling you she's scared if it doesn't
disarm you like she should go right
I'm not saying go to counselors
John you're throwing bombs you've got a
great you got a great perspective
there's this um it's an old
um counseling adage that we speak in
pictures but we think in words and how
often
my wife and I like hey I'm gonna be home
late
um for dinner tonight great late for me
I know my calendar I know that my last
meeting in immediate hit is eight
o'clock exactly late for her is 5 15.
yeah right yep and so she had a picture
of what late was I had a picture what it
was and we both used the word late but
we missed each other and so right maybe
it may be because you're a better person
than me it is a matter of hey when we
said you were going to give money to
your kids I didn't realize it was a
thousand dollars I thought it was 50.
and I think that who knows I'm looking
at the words newly married and that's
kind of where my my ring ring ring is
going off because that first year you
don't you don't know what you're doing
dude I'm 20 years I'm still alive
okay I had this thought the other day do
we have time for this I I had this
thought the other day I was like okay a
kid you when we raise our kids they're
in our home until they're 18 years old
and we're just teaching them how to just
be in the world right they don't know
anything and then after that then you
get married and you think that somehow
in one year in a couple months you're
going to be good to go and it's like it
took you 18 years to just learn how to
exist in society without being a total
jerk and now we have to be married
combined with a whole other person and
we think we're just gonna just skate
through it in like one two years and
then like be pros at it well absolutely
especially when
if if our kids got married that your
kids would have grown up in in the
Warsaw house two wonderful parents
my kids would have grown up in the
deloney house one wonderful picture two
wonderful parents and they would have
had very different understandings of how
the world works and what relationships
look like yes and so they've got to
figure out how not to recreate what they
saw mom and dad do good or bad but to
create something new and magical for
them yes right and that just takes time
it takes time so I'm looking at this
from Rachel and I'm thinking okay you're
newly married and there's there's more
Dynamics to this than it I don't want to
say typical there's more Dynamics to
this some people get married and it's
just you and me for the first time ever
never lived together and then some
people get married it's like oh I'm
bringing three kids into three this is
his second dance yeah
so uh this is this is this is a lot here
hopefully Rachel out of all of the
hundreds of millions of things that we
just said you'll pull something out that
is helpful to you but give yourself a
little bit of Grace counseling John I
love me some counseling Christian
Counseling any couples counseling put me
on yeah it's that's I wouldn't be
sitting here if it wasn't I just earlier
today after talking with my wife I said
I'll call my counselor and she goes
that's a good idea that was today I love
it I love it that's so so good
um what is
so let's say right let's say Rachel's
husband sits down and says all right I'm
in let's do this budget thing okay where
do they start you know here's the thing
once he says let's do this budget
today that's a great place to start you
find your budget find something that's
good you know here we kind of like to
identify the personality types like is
she a spender is he a saver because if
you can kind of identify that early on
you're kind of going to know those
points of contention ahead of time and
so them working that budget together is
going to tell each other a lot about
each other so it's like if they sit down
maybe he says all right let's do this
budget and they sit down and she
immediately sees that he's like his eyes
are like glazed over tuning out she can
probably assume okay he's not a nerd
he's not he's he's a free spirit he
might be more of a spending type and if
she's like oh my gosh I love these
numbers I just love filling in the line
items then she's probably more of a nerd
she could be a saver or a spender but
doing the budget together tells you so
much about each other and you both need
each other the spender needs somebody
who's going to uh balance them who's a
saver you know the free spirit needs
somebody who's more of a nerd to keep
them balanced so it's a balancing act
it's a dance but getting that budget
together and of course you know John I'm
talking about the baby steps all day
work those baby steps there you go all
right we'll be right back triple eight
eight two five five two two five on the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
yeah foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to nest sweet.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show triplet eight
two five five two two five I'm John
deloney joined by Jade warshaw and we
are taking your calls on your mental
health your marriage your relationships
your money whatever's going on Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
and for real
taxes are the worst they're so confusing
and if you buy what some tax services
out there say you might think you'll
never get a grasp on taxes and you
should even try right everyone's telling
you you're stupid you don't
we think you're smarter than that here
at Ramsey Solutions and you deserve the
truth so here's today's tax tip are you
ready
don't let fear of owing the IRS stop you
from filing your taxes early tax bills
aren't due until April 18th even if you
file now so filing early gives you time
to make a plan and pulled money together
now if you can't pay at all by the
deadline send what you can then set up a
payment plan with the IRS online they
can charge interest and penalties though
so pay it off as quickly as possible and
to avoid this situation again take a
fresh look at what you're paying the IRS
during the year you may need to have
more money withheld from your paycheck
or make quarterly payments if you have a
small business you have questions talk
with a Ramsay trusted Pro like one of
our endorsed local providers or national
Partners this is what I do
because I don't know what I'm doing they
can walk you through your tax return and
do the filing or if you're comfortable
filing online check out Ramsay smart tax
federal filing is just 19.95 right now
so there's no hidden fees and Jade I'll
tell you this the last few years I've
done Ramsey smart tax this year got more
complicated messy so I called the Ramsay
trusted Pro yeah all along the way dude
it's they've made it so easy for me yeah
and it takes all the drama out of it
right so go to ramseysolutions.com tax
to learn more and file with confidence
that's ramseysolutions.com
tax let's go to JT and the 505 out in
Albuquerque what's up JT
this is John Jade that's it what's up
man
thank you guys for taking my call I
appreciate it absolutely my brother
what's up
so
I'm in a situation which I'm very
fortunate to be in but uh I bought a
foreclosure about five six years ago and
I've redone everything from the floors
to the ceilings put in running water and
Heat
it's uh
it's it's security for my son and my
wife and I and there's a part of me
that's wondering if I should sell it and
kind of use the money to do other things
like maybe start a business or
go into something else besides property
which I know is very secure but at the
same time I just I don't feel like the
opportunity that I want or she wants to
hear in New Mexico and you know we're
just kind of trying to figure out if we
should sell this place when you say
security is this are you saying secure
like you've got your own home or is do
you have another house somewhere and
this is just a project
no this is my primary residence and
is it paid for
it is okay what's it worth
you know I got it for 30 and I can
probably sell for about 150.
and do you want to leave New Mexico
I think so between water security over
the next 50 years and you know
trying to find opportunity I just I
think it's time I'm sure my parents and
her parents don't feel the same way but
um
because you guys have kids or
one kid okay how old are you man
I am 28 28. so JT
um there's a
Jade will walk you through the the math
part of this but let me
bam
in a lot of ways I feel like I'm talking
to myself
10 or 15 years 10 or 15 years ago
um
I had created quite an anxious life for
myself and for my family
financially I was working way too much I
owed too much I wanted a life that
looked like X and Y and Z and every time
I got close to it then I moved the
finish line moved on me right and then I
started looking at I was in West Texas
so I was right down the road from you
and I was looking at well what about
this and if this happens and then in 25
years this might happen and the Ogallala
is going to go dry I started creating
these catastrophes
and what happened in short order is my
body started reacting to those
catastrophes as though they were
happening right now
even though they were all could bees
might bees maybes even probably of the
next 50 or 100 years
and what happened in my home at least
and I'll just say this in the home of
thousands of other people I've worked
with over the last
last decade
is people around me started feeling
electric because I was hard to be around
because I was always predicting the next
bad thing and the next thing what about
this what about this and then I'm
working and then I'm trying to earn my
worth and it just created a mess I was
very hard to be married to not because I
was a bad guy but because I could never
see
the sun come up
and so here's what I want to tell you I
think you could sell this house and
y'all can move to another place
but you're going to move to another
place and you're going to have gone with
you
and that same anxiety in that same
stress and that same I gotta work work
work because it's all coming down that
guy's going with you man
and it wasn't until a completely
unhooked from all the nonsense I went
and got myself some help and went and
got myself around some people that I
knew loved me some other men in my life
that were my friends that I could just
go spend like it took me years to heal
and now I really believe with all my
heart I could pretty much move wherever
because I've got a I've gotta build a
non-anxious life for me and my family is
that is that ringing a bell tell me I'm
crazy
now that that's pretty that's hidden
home pretty hard okay all right all
right so dude I mean I would not
you were one of the few people in the
history of the world to have a paid for
home
I don't think that I Jay tell me if I'm
crazy I would not risk my uh my family's
primary home
on something that might happen in 50
years and I'm gonna start a business
that's going to be my exit strategy it
just sounded like you were not clear on
what the path forward was and so I I
don't want to run from something if I'm
running I want to know exactly what I'm
running to right and I want to have a
very clear plan that's thought out that
is not based on fear that's not based on
a series of uh what-ifs do you know what
I'm saying I want to make sure that it's
something that is worthwhile
yeah and that's just I know John is
hitting the mental health side of it
that I mean that's a financial side of
it is what's the plan we're not going to
just go oh let's sell our house it would
be cool if we could start some kind of a
business does that make sense and and
maybe there's more likes to it that you
didn't explain here on the air but it
kind of felt haphazard am I wrong
you know it is I mean I don't have like
a specific plan yet but I got things I'm
trying to weigh out so
yeah so let's wait yeah you've got a
body that's electric my brother
this sense that I've got to keep moving
if I stop moving it's going to catch me
whatever it is and hey one of my best
friends in the world is a water law
professor I know how bad it is it
doesn't look good like I'll be honest
like I'm with you
and
is selling my family's primary home
right now with a young kid
is this the path out
or it sounds like a desperate scary I'm
just gonna start sprinting and hopefully
I get to somewhere wherever I'm going
yeah I'd say that sounds pretty accurate
and it does sound kind of foolish when
you first have one what's your what's
your wife saying I'm just curious what's
your wife saying about this JT
uh you know
she's kind of down for whatever she's
ready to leave but you know again it's
paid off so we have the security but
there's lack of opportunity and so you
know we just kind of keep ping pong back
and forth and really kind of getting
know where it feels like JT you just
said it man
when somebody tells me that their wife
is quote unquote down for whatever you
know what that means she's tired of
fighting you
he's hanging on
damn that hit home too okay come on John
so listen listen listen
I want you to hang on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy of on your past change
your future it's my book I want you to
read it I'm gonna send you redefining
anxiety too I'm gonna send you both
those books and tonight I want you to
take your wife out for Valentine's
dinner and say honey for the first time
before we make any plans we start
running things and selling things I'm
gonna go talk to a counselor for the
first time and I'm going to commit to
get myself well and stable and then
we're going to start making some
long-term plans together but I'm in this
for the Long Haul with you and I love
you and I'm gonna get myself well start
there my brother I'm proud of you and
thank you for the call we'll be right
back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Valentine's Day
you the sappy love song
cue the big bags of gummy candy man
gummy candy not chocolate come on I have
eaten my body weight in gummy candies
today somebody brought in some gummy
heart things and
I'm not gonna go to the bathroom for
like three weeks I've got a lot of gummy
candy in my body okay listen we've got
Valentine's Day pickup lines
and oh hey I didn't know we have all
these Ramsay dating groups so we'll tell
you all about them our very own Chris
Russell and Will Smith came up with the
top 10 Ramsay pickup lines not the Will
Smith not the Will Smith we have our own
we have our own we have Will Smith 3.0
he's awesome
dude's awesome all right uh you go first
all right why are you gonna make me say
this one first the first pickup line is
this you're finer than the print on
George Campbell's podcast oh gross
that's Insider it is Insider
um all right uh you're so hot
my debt snowball is melting love it love
that one if that
if Sam warshaw said that to me I'm
closing the door
and the other side of it that's all I'm
saying I'm
I had a dollar for every time I thought
of you I'd be a baby steps millionaire
girl gross
[Music]
good thing I just got term life
insurance because when I saw you my
heart stopped who oh Lord how did
these two guys work at our oh my gosh
all right I oh I okay when I saw you
stop when I saw you my jaw dropped like
the value of a new car we
60 percent all right I'm in on that but
I like that one I like that one
uh
I'm making my will and I want
I'm making my will and I want to list
you as a beneficiary I need your phone
number dude that's just creepy that is
kind of gross that's just weird all
right oh gosh the good news I'm debt
free the better news I'm also date free
I don't know I don't know about that one
that's a head scratcher no I'm in for
that I'm in for that I'm date free what
does that mean you don't what is it I
don't know I don't know okay sorry guys
yeah it's more something you would tell
your buddy I don't have a date I have a
date
I've got money but I ain't got a girl
okay okay is uh
what's up ladies is your name uh Fannie
Mae because you've got my interest oh my
gosh
okay okay
wow okay
um I'm falling for you faster than the
price of Bitcoin I like that one oh yeah
that's that's salty though that's a
little salty as well and uh now I think
officially across the country
um we only have seven people still
listening to the show they've moved on
to other other programming for you seven
who are left I got you
the final Ramsay pickup line
it's tax season
wanna file jointly we could save
hundreds we could save dozens of dollars
all right hey so there's a Ramsay dating
groups uh singles divorces struggling to
find people to date who are like-minded
when it comes to money and finances
people are posting to Ramsay baby steps
millionaires face group for advice group
members pointed people to different Dave
Ramsey online dating groups people
looking for connection on their
financial and love journey I I'm not mad
at that no dude I'm all in I'm all in
yeah I think if you're dating look
when I was dating I didn't know about
money the way I know about now but I
yeah you want to marry somebody I mean
we talk about it all the time who's on
the same page as you or that you're
you're going in the same direction right
and you have the same values uh
surrounding money and how how you spend
it so that's good I can't think of
something that was further from my mind
when I was dating so I I wish I had that
much foresight look I I can't say that I
like one at life with this because you
know y'all know how much debt we came in
with and let me just tell you can I just
say this real quick when Sam and I were
dating not like engaged we didn't talk
about money at all I just I didn't think
I did notice a couple of things like I
noticed like he put gas on a credit card
once and I was like oh that's
interesting not that I was smart with
money I just noticed that then when we
got married was the first time we really
talked about it and when he told me how
much student loan debt he had oh Lord
y'all thank God Sam warshaw is good
looking this man is a snack but his debt
when it came in I was like okay
okay and then we paid it off do you talk
about these things a number of times my
wife said God help you I'm so glad
you're good looking that's exactly right
there okay look it does help if you
can't be out here uh looking like a
catcher's mitt you know coming through
coming through with 300 000 of debt too
you gotta have one or the other all
right so Dave Ramsey online dating
a couple thousand members Dave Ramsey
dating group and by the way this isn't
for dating Dave he has spoken for this
is people who are like-minded who are
following baby steps I don't want to
fight with Sharon Ramsey Dave I wouldn't
Dave Ramsey Christian dating bless this
hot mess with several hundred members
Dave Ramsey's baby steppers dating page
okay and here are some questions to
ponder
um
Jade let's rapid fire these what do you
think when should you start talking
about money with someone you're dating
if you think you might get engaged soon
you don't think before that
um
okay now you're making me I thought this
is rapid fire
it's like major traffic
now stop and think and not be rapid I I
think that when you start seeing okay
there's like the basic things that I
like about this person let's take it the
next layer deep because at first it's
like all right they're kind they've got
they're integral like it's those base
level stuff they've got your character
now let's take it a step deeper and I'm
observing uh now you're just commenting
on on actions behaviors you're seeing
yeah I'm observing oh they paid gas for
they pay for their gas or the credit
card interesting or like you keep
um
uh you didn't tip well yeah that's a big
one you're stingy
um or you keep not taking me to a
restaurant you keep uh getting macaroni
and cheese at home no we would have been
finished we would have been done the
first the first offense no three strikes
on that one all right when do you share
your debt
when you're married okay
so you talk about it yeah yeah before
but not so when you're just dating or
you get engaged all right we're gonna
start sharing her debt no when you're
engaged I think if you both have debt
start paying on it separately or if one
side of it has debt I think it shows
really good faith for them to be like
hey I know I'm bringing this into the
marriage especially if you've spoken
about it I'm going to start paying it
off now awesome and then when you get
together you combine forces and you
can't be stopped right
um when do you talk about what are your
money goals are they aligned I like this
I mean yes I I like this one less about
I my wife and I have had this
conversation recently and um our smart
investor pro has reached out to say hey
we didn't have a just a just a catch-up
conversation the market was bananas last
year and
I don't think my wife and I have ever
sat down and said what are our money
goals I think we've shut down and said
what do we want our life to look like
um what does security look like for us
what is where do we want to live what
kind of home do we want to have for our
kids to come home to and it's been so
that that particular phrase is is not
something that's spoken to us but the
idea that we're going to talk about
where we want to go and how we're going
to get there I love that is is how we so
it's all I think the idea of
what is what does life look like for you
what do you want this thing to look like
when you're when it's all said and done
for you knowing that when you're 19 yeah
it's gonna look different or you're 25
is gonna look different all right you're
you're reading my mail on that because I
I rarely just set goals yeah I'm a
strictly based on values I'm like what
do we value in our life and when it
comes to money I think that's a
phenomenal way to approach it do we
value uh who maybe the wife values being
able to stay home with the kids maybe
and I think that when you do have those
conversations approaching it from that
there's so much more tied to it it's not
just like oh I want to have thirty
thousand dollars like that's great like
that's a a goal to check off on that
list on that path toward that those
values that you that you cherish but
yeah I love that John if your money goal
is not tied to values or not tied to a
picture of how you want your life to be
I cannot emphasize this enough you will
have a million dollars net worth and you
will be as Hollow as an old rotted log
absolutely or you can have half a
million dollars you can have a hundred
thousand dollars and you're leaning into
your values and goals and your life will
be incredible right so tie those things
to your
um to your goals Valentine's Day good
folks this is your last warning make
sure you don't forget if you have
forgotten take care of your loved ones
this is the Ramsey show another hour in
the books we'll see you soon
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jay if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsesolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do the work they love and create
action amazing relationships give us a
buzz at triple eight eight two five five
two two five I'm John deloney joined by
my good friend Jade warshaw and we have
set this place on fire and we are taking
your calls on money life your mental
health your marriage whatever's going on
we got you triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to Eric
in Long Island New York what's up Eric
hey John how are you hey Jade Happy
Valentine's Day what's going on we're
doing great my man what's happening
uh so I have a question okay I'm re I'm
retired uh
uh I'm 53 years old my wife is 55 she
still works
I make about a hundred thousand uh being
retired and she makes about close to the
same about 80 85
uh so my whole life I've always saved
put money into uh my 401s and everything
like that right now I got like 1.5
million in there she's got about a
million maybe a little bit more in hers
so between the two of us we got close to
three million dollars in retirement
uh funds we have two kids our kids
colleges or you know we saved up enough
money for that I got about a hundred
thousand dollars in the bank right now I
have two houses
uh with mortgages and I have three cars
with car payment
uh fortunately for me I can withdraw
from my uh 401 it's really not a 401 but
similar what is it uh
it's a 457 without uh penalty
so you don't have to be a certain age
nope yeah well I had to be 50 before
when I retired yeah you are the poorest
wealthy man I've spoken to in a long
time okay
yes
that that I got three car payments that
are kind of killing me you know and why
I was why would you do this to yourself
you're too smart you're a
multi-millionaire yeah the problem is
not your car payments the problem is you
keep choosing debt when you don't have
to why do you have two houses
well once a rental I I it's a positive
thing no no no it's not it's taking your
soul from you
well I mean it does pay for itself and
then some so I do make something more
off of it it's not like it's it's
costing me any money I just manage it uh
so but it makes me about 1500 a month
I mean after all said and done you're
saying it's not costing you anything but
you're calling in this show I promise
it's costing you something something
okay let's talk let's talk we we beat
you up enough let's talk a little bit
okay I love you Eric because you you're
so good you've done it so you you know
what you are Eric you're America in all
the best ways and all of like you have
made it you've done so great
clearly you're excellent at your trade
you're excellent at managing money and
then you do the dumbest stuff right on
top of it and it's like oh man oh man
okay you you have too much bottom line
I'm just gonna shoot you straight you
make too much money you have too much of
a a net worth to to have this much debt
and to to be uh treating your money this
way so let's change it let's change it
you guys have got like you said almost 3
million in your retirement I heard you
say you had a thousand a hundred
thousand dollars saved just liquid
yes we got a hundred thousand dollar
State well there's probably more than
that right now probably like one Thirty
okay or something like that but I you
know that uh and I got another 300 saved
for just my two kids college fund okay
and that's the college okay and they
they're they're in college so that's
that's kind of going quickly both of
them are in college right now and that's
kind of going quickly but uh let's talk
about these three cars how much are go
through each of them and tell me what
you owe on on each of the three
I owe uh well one we just bought was was
my wife's car and I owe about uh uh 48
on it
and I'm curtailing I'm curtailing my my
feelings right now big time I need you
to know it keep going 48 you just bought
it this year keep going
uh the other one is my daughter's but
they both use it I only have one car and
I owe about 20 on that and then my my
truck that I drive I owe about 35.
I'm sorry can you go back to the
daughters are they paid for you said
they both use it
they both use it yeah they both use I
only got one call for them and they both
they they switch on and all is that the
20 000 one
yes got it okay that's for the girls
okay so you have cash right now to pay
all these off today why would you not
well that was my question like I was I
wanted to just take I didn't want to
touch my that that to me is like my
emergency funding at a hundred thousand
I didn't want to touch that well you do
need you do need an emergency fund but
you only need three to six months
and no no I I get it but but being that
so so my question to you guys is being
that I can withdraw from my uh
retirement fund would it be easier just
to take the hundred thousand dollars out
pay the cars off be done with them I
have no credit card bills
no and just live live my life that way
you leave your retirement if you if you
cash out your time right now you are
locking in
losses a crazy down Market oh God why
would you do that you you'd have to take
out a hundred thousand dollars
I know but when when am I going to be
able to use that money I mean when I'm
70 years old and sitting in a wheelchair
stalking cars for a store I know I
actually you know what I actually think
that's a great question that we need to
spend more time on I I think there is a
absolute
um uh there's an absolute conversation
to be had around waiting until we have
all this money at the end I I get you
but you have a hundred and twenty
thousand dollars in cash
here's the thing here's what I truly
truly think that you need to do uh Eric
I want you to I want you to pay these
cars off and I want you to feel it
and when you pull it from your savings
you are going to feel it
if you pull it from a a million dollar
fund that you have you're not going to
feel it and you're going to go well that
was easy and then I'm gonna see you at
the dealership again next year buying a
2024 car
and I'm gonna be angry with you like I
am right now I want you to feel the pain
of this and go dang it I am never going
to do that again that was so stupid
because here's the thing you're you
gotta feel it and I want you to stop
this behavior and I want you to stop it
right now now that 48k vehicle I know it
was a brand new car I paid off keep it
and pay it off you got a million dollar
net worth I'm not telling you to sell
anything keep three to six months of
savings pay off the cars and get out of
debt for good for good and yes have the
conversation about hey what do we want
to do with this money as like we want to
go on vacations do you want to pay off
this rental home that we're one weird
policy in New York now that y'all have
ever had weird government policies in
New York from not being able to have
renters or we have to kick them out or
they can't charge we can't charge rent
whatever it's coming pay your thing off
man pay your house off you have too much
net worth to have this much debt pay it
off pay it off and be free
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
hey we got this article
um gosh it's just a couple days ago off
of
um Yahoo finance
inflation's taking quite a toll we know
that half of Americans say their
personal financial situations are worse
now than they were a year ago more than
any time since the Great Recession
but there's something deep or according
to a Gallup survey released Wednesday
which asked a thousand adults across the
U.S about their past and future finances
not only is this the first time since
2008 2009 that at least 50 percent of
Americans report feeling worse off
financially than they were a year ago
it's the only time aside from those two
years that they have that that many
responded negatively since they started
asking questions in 1976. wow and while
economists are still torn on whether
we're heading towards a recession on in
the unemployment rate stands at a
53-year low I just want to put that in
context
when you're having a debate when
academics
um and I don't say that pejoratively
that's that's my background when when
thinkers are saying well is it recession
or is it not is it
that means things haven't fallen off a
cliff that means things are tough things
are messy things are are not as we want
them to be
but is not 2008 and 2009 yeah and it
doesn't take a financial expert we've
got Rising interest rates right
um then we've got the FED jacking with
things and prospective home buyers have
been driven from the market credit card
debt is more expensive public layoffs at
high profile companies like so here's
what I'm hearing Jade
there's a ton of media messages
screaming at everybody telling them that
this is the end of time and it's just
not the end of time in fact if you keep
saying it enough
you we will run this sucker into the
ditch and make it the end of time you're
reading my mind right now gotta stop I'm
gonna take a page out of your playbook
turn the news off turn it off turn it
off turn it off because my guy John is
exactly right it's it's it it's playing
into your mindset if you hear that over
and over and over Doom and Gloom Doom
and Gloom we we can't get ahead
inflation it's driving up our grocery
prices and I'm not saying that people
aren't feeling a pinch and that people
aren't struggling I'm not saying that
but there's a difference between going
like just wallowing in that daily
because you start to succumb to to
fearful practice and you start doing
things like taking out helocs and and
thinking oh the only way I'm gonna get a
car is to to get a you know I have to
pay this 17 you know 717 dollars a month
this is the only way because car prices
are you know and you start doing the
dumb stuff that goes along with all of
that right when it's like okay let me
just let me take a break here yeah and
like pull back and go okay I can't solve
inflation I can't solve what's going on
at the White House I can't solve the job
market but me as a problem I can solve
yep right everything you can solve
that's right and no amount hear me say
this no amount of watching the news is
going to bring down the price of eggs no
amount of watching the news in Doom
scrolling is going to bring down the
prices of gas and so I can go to the
grocery store and listen you know we had
to cut out my house
I hate to even say it bacon you know
what I love more than most things in the
world bacon but it's 111 a package yeah
so I stopped and the moment we like my
wife said hey bake is so expensive and I
was like let's just cut it out man and
what's wrong with that but but here's
the deal once I made that choice
is a choice to be miserable it's a
choice
I just said hey let's let's cut it out
it's too expensive right now I'm then
going on about my day I'm not gonna give
some Media Company the opportunity to
make me miserable does that make sense
that I'm giving you a look I'm giving
you a slow clap I'm done with it because
I I said the same thing the other day
you go into the grocery store you see
the price of eggs and and you want to go
on social media you want to tell
everybody you know oh my gosh the price
of eggs you want to freak out about it
buy a bagel
sorry can you just buy a bagel yes can
you get some cereal yes that's all I'm
saying
didn't please don't mishear me I've got
10 chickens get chickens don't mishear
me there's there's a single mom that is
crying every night that's right she
can't breathe but the majority there is
a vast majority of us we just like to
get on the bandwagon of Crazy Town like
whatever the news is talking about
you're just texting your buddy you're
sending Fox News links I love Fox news
by the way but you're sending Fox News
links to everyone you know the worst
possible stories and they found another
China balloon they found another you
know what does that mean go buy gold
you're like going bananas yeah and all
you're doing is disconnecting yourself
from your family your community your
friends and here's the worst part we're
not solving the problems what if you
just opened up your budget and went okay
deep breath
we're over three hundred dollars where
can we find it okay maybe you know but
Susie is is taking piano lessons bass
guitar lessons Jiu Jitsu less maybe we
can cut out one of those for now okay
we're spending this much on groceries
what can we do maybe we can start buying
some bagels maybe we can cool cool it
out or maybe I can pick up a little bit
of extra hours that's right maybe I had
this planned for 2023 we're gonna spend
more time together
life there was a curveball and so I'm
gonna have to go pick up another Uber
shift for a season that's right we have
to stop buying this thing that we love
we're gonna have to we have to punt that
vacation let's go ahead and tell our
parents now that we're not coming in
this summer for that trip because we
can't afford it we're gonna have to we
were gonna buy a house we want to buy a
house this August so bad it hurts it's
not gonna happen let's just sit in that
sadness let's be broken hard to get
let's go for a long walk together let's
figure it out and then we're gonna see
what it looks like around Christmas of
next year that's right any choice other
than those choices is a choice to be
miserable stop doing that to ourselves
so good John key word that you said it's
a season yeah and it's a season if
anybody listening is like maybe you're
not the one that's like like just loves
Chris some people just love drama can we
just say that maybe you're not the one
that loves drama if you're really going
through it can just hear us say it's a
season it's a season and you'll get
through this I promise you if you just
take a clear head sit down and look at
the controllables and control your
controllables you will get through this
I promise you that and reach out to
folks when you need the help Reach Out
Reach Out Reach Out reach out
um that's that's the other thing I got
and we'll we'll move on because I can
talk about this all day I could too the
more that we are pumping this into our
heads into our eyes and our ears about
how awful everything is it's a natural
psychological tendency I start to my
gaze goes to my own belly button how can
I protect me and mine and when your body
feels like it's scared it quickly it's
instantly it's a protective measure but
it divides the world up between Us's and
them's and I miss that single mom who
can't breathe who's trying to figure out
how to buy groceries because I'm too
busy thinking it's all coming down
instead of keeping my eyes up and
looking at people in my neighborhood and
my community and my grocery line that I
can reach in there and say I got you
ma'am I got you so good and that's what
neighbors do that's what communities do
and the more we're like it's it
everything's on fire it takes a very
special person to override your
psychology and look around for others in
the midst of a fire right so turn the
news off turn the mess off get the news
you need and get out right right get in
get out John what you said is so good if
you're listening to this because some
people are kind of flying above the
storm right now and and that if that's
you that's a great place to be
um we all should aspire to that like
when 2008 comes when covet comes man I
hear Dave say it all the time what a
great place to be when you're just a
spectator yeah right and if you're
listening to the show and you're a
spectator buy somebody's groceries
tonight yeah on the way home on the way
home look at somebody who's trying to
fill up with gas and they're looking
through their purse for coins yeah and
just put your put your debit card in and
get it and ask no questions and
Happy Valentine's Day Happy Valentine's
Day that's right start uh stop looking
at your own belly button and start
looking up around at your neighbors man
and you're gonna find a whole different
take on this it's all coming down you
know I I was reading
said history doesn't repeat itself
people do
pistol history is this other thing
that's operating I mean we're the ones
that drives it right so and in a in a
time like this I'm like
people what does it say Americans are
feeling worse about their money since
the Great Recession okay
stop doing the dumb things that people
did during the Great recessions don't do
it again
don't be the people who repeat
themselves that makes history repeat
itself you know what I'm saying do
something different
hey you know what that's that's the
magic mental health moment
if it's not working stop doing that
thing do something different do
something different we see how this has
played out before let's just do
something different
stop choosing misery we'll be right back
on the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
in Columbus Ohio what's up Ian
hi Jade and John how are you guys doing
today we're partying dude what's up so
I'm a firefighter right now
um I have a pension 20 22 years so I can
retire I just kind of got going
um extension I still pay social security
and then I have tsp in my investing
option in that and I also have the
opportunity to present itself to
make a lot more income also as a
firefighter but no pension of my option
there would be just 401K only
okay
so it's a pretty substantial difference
in the pay and the hours so currently I
work 144 hours of pay period so 48 Hours
one week 96 hours the second week okay
and I do not get overtime until 53 hours
a week okay and I'm gonna make about 17
an hour so I bring home
I I've been putting about 400 a check
into my Roth so I bring home about 2 000
a day you make 17 an hour as a fireman
yes sir and that's just for the right
that's just with the raise
um I had to do it part-time elsewhere I
make about 12. oh gosh okay okay
I know John has mad questions come on
John I just was driving this morning
every Tuesday morning me and my son go
eat at Waffle House for breakfast
together
and there was a sign at McDonald's that
said like 20 bucks an hour yeah
so I used to work private transport as
an EMT and I made about I made about in
the mid-20s about five years ago when I
started I only made about 11. so for
whatever this is a big increase with
covid and the demand for that job so you
are really you're this is your heart
your heart is just to serve your
community
um so I I also get a good bit of money
from the military as well I am service
connected veteran so I get about 46 000
a year from that so okay I don't really
need to work this is just what I enjoy
doing so what about job two so you just
kind of gave me the layout on job one
with the pension you know the job job
two is 36 hours a week I have the option
to work 48 every other week 48 hours
with an extra shift but it's not
mandatory and it starts out at 45 an
hour yes wow yeah do it for many reasons
you get your life back brother for
multiple reasons yeah it's about 110 000
a year base salary Bye Felicia bye easy
and and let's for the people listening
let's explain why a you're making more
money for less hours so there's that
that's easy easy math easy money
um it's still in a field that you love I
mean you're still being a firefighter
right yes okay do you have to move or
anything it's it's actually closer to
home hey come on so so that's reason
number two and reason number three I
like you in a 401k better than I like
you in a pension
yeah because I think the pension may be
eighteen hundred dollars a month by the
time I get to use it are you able to
transfer the current
Pension funds into your 401k can you do
like a direct transfer to move that over
uh I don't know I so I'm Federal right
now and the job
alternative job is called Federal
contractor so it's it's different
I know I can I can access the money I'm
putting into the pension I just don't
know what I'm allowed to do with it I
would just check around and find out if
you're able to move that over only just
because pension money you know a 401k is
more stable
I've only been full-time with the
pension since October okay so there's
not much in it yeah I was part-time for
a year beforehand trying to get full
time and Ian let me let me give you
here's my Matrix for this this type of
job I've done the exact thing I went
from working for a government position
to a private position to now
I'm a YouTuber for God's sake so I've
made that influencer
um but let me tell you the Matrix I use
and I actually learned it by running
around with policemen and firefighters
doing crisis response okay it's I hold
in one hand
this could go sideways in a in a wild
crazy way and you above all people would
know that right and I hold on my other
hand but it probably won't
and so I always want to have a if it
does and this is just me right this is
just my dad is a homicide detective it
can all go down any moment I know that
and so I want to make sure I've got
something
you will not have a problem finding
another 12 an hour job for God's sakes
and on behalf of taxpayers who are not
First Responders I'm embarrassed for all
of us and I'm sorry that we have told
you that's what you're worth it's it's a
it's a it's a shameful moment in our
history okay with the owls I make about
80 000. well that's because you're
working yourself to death
I work two days on three days off the
schedule is not as terrible as it sounds
but I have a young child that I you're
still not it's still not fair that
that's all you're getting paid I love
that you're a hard worker but yeah dude
so here's um another kind of wrench out
of this so the alternative job that I'm
considering they are they're a plant
they uh I don't want to say what they do
exactly but they're a big plant and they
have numerous jobs okay I took an
entry-level job there a couple years ago
and worked there trying to get on the
fire department because it is Union so
my goal was to transition and then you
told me no spots would be open for
several years so I took that job for the
job I'm at currently so I'm going back
so I've worked there before and the
environment is a little uh toxic to say
the least especially in that part of the
in that part that fire department I've
heard I haven't witnessed it but I heard
it's a risk environment for uh mental
health okay so here's what I want you to
ask you're fine financially
you're fine unless you go do a bunch of
dumb stuff and borrow a bunch of money
that you can't pay back and please don't
be like my buddies who get out of the
military and go buy jacked up jeeps like
like if you take care of your money
um you do you have a jacked up G please
tell me no
no I got a big drug I knew you would
okay so
um so unless you're just make a bunch of
goofball decisions with your money
you're gonna be fine you got money
coming in from a couple of places and
you're young you can you can work I want
you to ask the question with you and
your wife about the quality of your life
and what kind of Life do you all want to
live moving forward you've put your
you've put your neck on the line for me
and my family for long enough and it's
time for you and your wife to sit down
and say what kind of Life do we want to
build for ourselves and our little one
and let's craft the job on the back end
of that
does that make sense and so if you want
to make great money work 36 hours a week
you've been in the military you know how
to deal with a boss that's running his
mouth like that may not be toxic for you
like you can you can brush your
shoulders off and move on yeah I can be
unhappy for 12 hours a day yeah well I
mean in in admit what's unhappy to some
might not be you might get there and be
like this is not bad guys
let's put out money I can put up with a
lot to put up with more in the military
for a lot less that's that's what I mean
and you might say
you know what I like my schedule I like
being with the guys I like two on four
off I like that life and it's it's wild
I got to work a lot they're not paying
me anything but I'm gonna stay with it
like that's and you might quit all this
and go work at a coffee shop for for 17
an hour but I I want you and your wife
to sit down and plan your life out what
kind of Life y'all want to have together
and then let's backfill it because you
got a couple of opportunities
professionally and you've got that
fallback money from your military
service well I have a question for you
Ian where do you see yourself in the
next five to ten years like what's
in-game for you career-wise or like
what's like that big you know shiny
Beacon that's like man if I could get
there or like that's this is what I'm
gunning for
um I mean right now it's just uh the
pension was kind of just my thing was I
just want to make sure that when my
daughter is grown that I can
make sure she's taken care of
I mean I I'm paying down my consumer
that I don't have a whole lot relatively
yeah I just want to get that taken care
of and good I take plenty of vacations
and make memories I love that I love uh
when when the why is the child and in
the family I love that I I also I just
don't want you to work to make money
though and I don't necessarily want you
to work for other people I want you to
make sure that what you're doing is
something that that you Ian enjoys that
you get joy out of that you get a sense
of purpose from as well I think that
it's All-Star that you're like yes my
daughter you know but I I would like
John I would um challenge you to search
a little bit deeper because I don't want
you just hopping from thing to thing
that makes this money and then this
makes that money and that'll make me a
little bit more money I I want you doing
work that matters because you enjoy it
um for multi for a multiple array of
reasons does that make sense and I'll
say this Jade that
um somewhere along the way we were told
to lie that a pension is the is this
safest way to have money when you're
older that's the Holy Grail yeah let me
tell you this one more one thing Ian
um you want your daughter to have
security moving forward that's awesome
the greatest sense of security she will
ever have is knowing that her Daddy
loves her and is there for her start
there my brother we'll be right back on
the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
scripture of the day is Romans 12 9 love
should be shown without pretending hate
evil and hold on to what is good
the Great and Powerful Jimi Hendrix says
when the power of love overcomes the
love of power the world will know peace
Dynamic the best uh all right let's go
to Alexandra in San Diego what's up
Alexandra
okay thank you thank you very so much
for what you do thank you so much for
calling what's up
hi so I just have a question about kind
of like the mindset issue I'm having
with combining finances so my husband
and I have actually been together for a
long time we've been together for 12
years married for seven but we never
joined our finances you know we were
young and we just thought it was smarter
to just keep it separate so avoid any
sort of issues everything was good for a
while but you know the way I was raised
is no matter how little you make you
always save even if it's five ten twenty
dollars a paycheck and the way he was
raised is pretty much opposite they had
a lot of money they blew through it he
didn't learn how to save he just learned
how to get into debt so here we are um
you know uh 11 years into being together
uh we started having some issues with
our marriage where he was just drinking
a lot spending a lot of money even
behind my back locked the credit cards
things like that so then we came to a
point about
um a couple maybe like seven eight
months ago to where we had a separation
for a little bit we thought we were done
but we're getting divorced um but you
know I guess God brought us back
together we talked through he decided to
get sober on his own thank God so it
wasn't me telling him like an ultimatum
or anything so now we're at a point
where I found Dave Ramsey and I've been
watched everything and I want to get to
the point where we can kind of start
fresh and kind of like almost like renew
our vows and we're gonna you know have
our finances be
um combined but my biggest struggle is
I've been trying I don't have too much
money saved I only have about 25 000
saved but it's taken me a long time to
get it um to this point and I just feel
like when I take on his debt I feel like
he committed a crime and I am having to
serve the sentence for it and I don't
know how to get out of that mindset so
that's what I'm calling you for so
number one
thank you for being honest and brave
okay I'm grateful for you okay it's been
y'all been through it okay
um
I know you are technically technically
still married you are not ready to be
fully committed to doing this thing
again yet
here's why you're I'm telling you you're
not you're you want to go you want to
get back in the boat but you want to
keep one foot on Shore because you're
not fully trusting that he's all in
or maybe you know that he's all in or it
feels like he's all in but your body is
reminding you on a daily basis hey we've
been through hell before why are you
getting back in that boat
and the scary thing about loving
somebody who struggles with any sort of
addiction
is that's the one time I might tell you
to have your own account is if somebody
is struggling with an addiction and they
are draining your money
and
right so that's a terrifying moment and
at the same time I'm telling you you
cannot have a marriage that works long
term unless you go all in
unless you risk getting hurt again
that's the only way marriage works
and you look at that that's what the
word vulnerability means I am giving you
permission to hurt me please don't
yeah and I think that's why we kept at
supper for so long because he could make
all the mess he can why and it never
affected me financially but it did it
affected you in so many ways it took
your soul from you
sure it took everything from you and by
the way if y'all are married and he dies
it's you can't be like no no no no
that's his side of the house take half
that half the couch that's just how that
works so you were living in a fantasy
you wanted the best part of being
married you love being around that guy
but you didn't want to deal with the
worst part is this guy's not trustworthy
and he's not safe
right right and so here you are you've
got a moment the deck is clear
you've got to decide am I going to go
all in and if I do go all in what are my
parameters for going all in
and that is I will not be in a situation
where I'm ever scared again and one of
the things that scares me is not knowing
how our money Works how what you're
spending stuff on where we're going to
end up financially am I going to have to
work when I'm 92 years old because my
husband drank our money away or spent
our money weight right so it's it's a
matter of I won't be in a situation
where I don't feel safe anymore
and if I don't know where the money is I
don't feel safe
yeah and I guess I'm just scared of the
future because who
I'm bored with them with the whole
Ramsey thing that we're about to start
that together but you never know when
you know if in a year he might do
something behind my back or like start
drinking again yeah but that's all
that's all that's all marriages uh the
great Esther apparel says the worst part
about a marriage is every day is a risk
every day you've been married 70 years
you wake up and you're both 90 and I
wake up and say
I love you will you love me today
that's marriage my wife can do something
crazy in a year I can do something crazy
like that's life that's that's it I've
got a close buddy of mine that was
driving his family home from a family
weekend and their car rolled over a
bunch of times they got out he didn't
that's marriage that's life yeah and so
I'm also emotionally attached to my
money to where like I feel like I'm
about to you know I've been sitting for
like almost 10 years to get to like
these like lousy 25 000 I'm about to
drain it to a thousand dollars just so
you can you know I could pay off all of
his stupid decisions it's yours it's
yours
it's not his and the as long as you use
that language then stay separated
when you're ready to say this is our
money because you can't expect him to
join accounts with you but you're not
joining with him on the other side of
this thing
if you're in you got to be here then if
you're in it's his debt and it's your
debt it's y'all's debt
okay well I think I'm gonna I think I'm
I really want to be all in
um but I guess you're right yeah I just
have to just take the risk otherwise
there's no either way Jay tell me if I'm
wrong here I can't think of another way
of going all in than going all in you've
got 25 000 call your own Bluff
um not too much actually about 11 000 on
his car two thousand and credit cards
left and uh about 15 in student loans
is he still actively creating debt like
is he in the face of you paying these
things off is he gonna go spend more on
a credit card
he's been really good so since he got
sober and we had this whole conversation
he started doing um Uber so he goes we
both go to school we both work full-time
but he also started doing you know the
Uber and Lyft at the same time so he's
working 14-hour days and he got his
credit cards down from like 15 000 down
to two and you know so he's helping me
he's busting it he's helping you're just
afraid isn't the the drinking you're
afraid he's going to go back to fall
back into that
or actually surprisingly not worried
about him relax relapsing I'm more this
is about your money more time this is
Alexander this is about your this is
about your money
it is I'm just so attached to it because
I work so hard to earn it that I don't
want to you know just pretty much see it
all go are you is it worth your marriage
no absolutely not I gotta say I feel
like we're talking a lot about him but I
feel like now it's you Alexander it's
you I feel like now you're I hate to say
it like this but I feel like now the
problem is shifted over to maybe now
you're the problem
y'all both are the problem but both the
solution you you've got to decide is
this is holding your secret holding your
little pacifier blankie that you feel
like keeps you safe is worth your Merit
and if it is have the courage to look
him in the eye and say you're not worth
twenty four thousand dollars and be done
with it let them let him go and
otherwise say I'm all in I've been
asking you to be all in I'm looking at
unchanged man you changed your entire
life he changed his friend's Circle he
changed his his the way his body copes
with stress and rejection and fear he's
working 17 jobs to pay his debts off
why don't you join him and be all in
because he sounds like he is now
yeah I know it's totally worth it I'm
definitely leaning towards that way it
just it just sucks
you can't lean you can't lean at altar
you jump you jump I go all in no one and
no one no one here is saying it's easy
here I'm like no no one here is saying
it's easy hey you can call us back in
three weeks and this could have ended
terribly that's the risk that's what
love is that's what marriage is that's
what friendship is that's what work is
it's all a risk
you just gotta ask yourself is he worth
that risk
and more importantly are you worth that
risk and I think the answer is yes I do
too I do too I think the answer is yes
all right I want to thank Jade and all
the guys in the booth Jade it's a good
time I feel like we're best friends now
I I'm just about to say I got a new best
friend and I only have I have zero best
friends so I've got one now that's
fantastic hey in America I want to thank
you for listening thanks for being with
us be kind to one another take care of
your money take care of your neighbors
we'll see you soon
foreign
[Music]
if you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramseysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]